[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and today we
have something very special my friend
chef chris oh will be joining us to show
us how to make the perfect korean
barbecue spread he's amazing he's the
previous winner of the great food truck
race previous winner of cutthroat
kitchen and just recently competed on
tournament of champions he's unstoppable
and today he has something super special
to show us a korean barbecue car i'm not
even kidding super exciting let's go
meet him hello chris hello
my goodness i'm so excited
i'm excited i'm so excited look at this
car you like it it is a korean bbq car
it is literally a cream barbecue cart
this is amazing thank you i can't even
believe the spread in front of me not
just a spread but what it's attached to
a freaking car uh i know can you okay
before we even begin can you tell us a
little bit about this car this whole
idea actually was spurned on by the
pandemic a lot of people couldn't go to
korean barbecue restaurants so we
decided why not bring the korean bbq
restaurant to them we took a car built
this barbecue table and now we're here i
need to know how you built it like how
did this come about cyan was so great to
like you know give us a car and let us
build this like amazing kind of concept
for us only a few like a few short
months and here we are okay so what are
the features we have a motorized korean
barbecue table that comes out
we have a tv the car lowers to like the
right table height we have strobe lights
we have speaker systems i mean you name
it we got it korean bbq is one of my
favorite foods and the fact that i could
have it anywhere anytime yes impeccable
yep this is so cool but it's good we can
take it anywhere so for those who don't
know what korean bbq is what is korean
barbecue if you don't know what korean
barbecue is then you need to like get
out from underneath get your life
together you need a noah cream barbecue
and barbecue the way i like to describe
it it's like cirque du soleil on the
table i love that this is not just a
meal now it's more of an experience as
you can see you know what other kind of
meal can you have where you have hot
coals in the middle table with raw meat
that you're going to grill up primal
indulgence all these side dishes we call
pancham's i like to describe these as
like the free breadsticks and salad you
get an olive garden but better not
better i actually don't i do love the
olive garden
i love all again everything you're
explaining very important parts of
korean bbq like you need to have certain
elements to have korean bbq the protein
the side dishes the sauces the wraps so
starting with the protein what are the
must-have proteins for kbbq you're gonna
have your carbi and then secondly we
have the burgogi that we made earlier
this is just like sliced ribeye same
marinade as the carby and then lastly we
have like the pork belly which is my
favorite so moving on to side dishes yes
otherwise known as bunch
honestly if panchan's not at korean bbq
i don't feel like i get the full
experience no i personally judge a
korean barbecue restaurant on their side
dishes i also judge a korean restaurant
based on their pancha if it's sweeter i
know the rest of their dishes are going
to be sweeter too what are the must have
side dishes my personal favorite is
potato salad that's like the first thing
to go on any korean bbq table there's
that one bad person though who always
takes the full scoop are you dude no
okay good you're good but i don't i do
know people you know who you are it's
always the japchae and the potato salad
if you take all of it in the first thing
god you are not a people person
so what are the side dishes we have here
today so we have spinach we have potato
salad we have garlic jalapeno bean
sprouts radish kimchi corn cheese chop
che chopchat is korean noodles
stir-fried
another very important element the wraps
rice paper sliced daikon shiso leaves
lettuce
we say rice paper yeah sauces sauces
iconic sauces the trio of sauces plus
more yup what are the sauces that we
need to have so you to have sesame oil
salt and pepper that's one a lot of
people don't do like when you see a
little like a little bit of salt on your
table ask the server to pour your little
sesame oil
wait are people not doing that not my
friends
not my korean friend
they like some people just like just the
salt what the same person that keeps
taking all the potato salad
and another underutilized sauce is the
samjhang yes you guys know what samsung
is it's like fermented soybean paste
gochujang garlic some sesame oil it's
like nutty savory goes well with so many
things let's dive into the protein
finally yes all right so what do you
wanna do you wanna start with the
cayenne you wanna start with the burgogi
i'll let you choose all right so since
kybe's closer to me let's do a cardboard
music to my ears and what are your tips
on like how to grill it correctly so
with carby so it's short rib i actually
like it a little bit more medium to
medium well because i feel like when
it's medium rare it's a little chewy so
i suggest while you're out there to cook
your car to be a little bit harder i
like char char is good
it changes the flavor completely it
brings that smokiness that just adds
that extra dimension to it and like with
such a good cut of meat you want to like
just take you know go all the way like
none of this like half-assed kind of
stuff just totally let's just go go for
the gusto and what about the grill like
what
is the ideal grill someone should be
using when having korean bbq at home it
all depends your card base and your
bulgogies you definitely want to try to
use an open face grill with some
charcoal or something because you want
the flames to like kiss the meat and
give you that real nice like you know
like that charred flavor kiss the meat i
love that phrase the best part on this
piece of meat is the meat around the
bone heart agree hands down eat the
cartilage off the short rib bones thank
you
this looks amazing cheers cheers
that's pretty good for being off the
back of a car it is the real thing if
not better
i get this question a lot are you
allowed to eat with your hands
yes
people always ask me is it okay is it
inappropriate is it disrespectful by you
with no words absolutely not eat however
you want if it gets into your mouth into
your stomach you're eating it right
unless you order rice and during all you
can eat what's the next meat we'll do
the uh the burgogi everybody yeah and
how did you make your book we take a
bunch of aromatics like onions garlic
ginger apple pear sesame oil honey black
pepper brown sugar some water mix it all
up put our thinly sliced ribeye in there
let it marinate for 24 hours and then
put that on there
and the apple pear does play a role in
the marinade right absolutely so the
apple bear helps like break down the
mussels and the meat to get a really
really nice tender piece of meat so when
you take that first bite of carb you get
the the umami from the soy sauce the
sweetness from the sugar and the honey
you get a little bite of the onion and
the ginger just like every bite has a
different like layer of flavor and i
like that you can mix and match
different things to create different
flavors in each bite i don't know but
you guys i'm gonna go for it
that's the best thing on the whole time
table you're like i'm really good
my potato salad i'm going to be that guy
and eat the whole thing korean bbq
places just use butane fuel
and just have a fire you're using
charcoal here does it change the texture
the flavor absolutely the charcoal
definitely gives you that nice smoky
flavor and it gives you that little char
that you have you can obviously tell
between a non-grilled meat versus a
grilled meat
because you're going to get that
smokiness you're going to get that crisp
char you can even smell the difference
when it's preheating the great thing
about korean barbecue there's only one
rule and that rule is there are no rules
i love that dig in cheer cheers i got a
crisp
oh my goodness you can taste the
charcoal
if you're making pogoji at home totally
okay to not have the charcoal but
chocolate definitely does take it to
that next level
not as good as potato salad
lastly we have the pork belly the
gochujang
pork belly and this has got pork belly
mixed with gochujang some honey some
thai chili sauce some garlic some
jalapeno some ketchup some sriracha so
your favorite meat yes this is like i
love pork belly to begin with um but
again like with the sugars the natural
sugars like the chili sauce and the
honey it's going to give a nice char
it's like game over whoa
there's always a designated person
cooking for korean barbecue
does it end up being you because it ends
up being me all the time yeah you would
think it would be me because i'm a chef
but you know why did you put that in you
are a chef you're literally a chef i
would purposely be at the end of the
table definitely not this close because
it's worked why would people put you to
work absolutely like hey chris
i see you cooking can you do this ah no
um
i'm like having a life crisis right now
i'm used to saying that i'm not a huge
fan of pork belly really but because
it's chewy and this is
melt-in-your-mouth sauce it's like it's
hard to describe it mine is super soft
like butter oh there are so many side
dishes i'm gonna take some yup i'm gonna
definitely grab a big scoop of potato
salad yes yes yes another korean bbq do
is take some kimchi yes throw it
on the grill oh my goodness absolutely
the potato salad oh yeah right pretty
muddy right not to toot your horn but
it is very delicious how did you make
your potato salad i boiled some potatoes
mix it with some apple pears some fresh
grapes some corn some eggs some kimchi
mayonnaise burakake some green onions
a lot of love i really like the addition
of the grapes i think that's very unique
yep it's like soft and tender has that
burst of sweetness yup it's amazing we
got to dig into this corn corn cheese
corn cheese is like so good the way it
just steams in your face oh my god you
cannot mess up this dish you only mess
up by not ordering it it's easy to make
it's packed with flavor that mayo gives
it that tanginess that punch there's
kimchi here how did you guys make your
kimchi this is actually our house-made
kimchi kimchi is so versatile the crazy
thing about kimchi is when i was growing
up i was so scared to like eat kimchi
especially like going to school and
doing that but like now kimchi is like
everywhere it's so cool how you know
korean like korean barbecue and the
korean culture is really like coming to
the forefront of this society people are
more accepting of it nowadays yep on
very lazy days i love to just
like kimchi to us is like mashed
potatoes and gravy to like americans
it's just like comfort food it has to be
there it's like the staple okay and we
need to talk about the steamed egg yes
so important as well how do you make it
so the steam bake is really simple to
make it's just eggs water a little
sesame oil a little salt you can you
know if you want to really kick it up
use something like shrimp paste that's
it i love the fluffiness of it it's like
super refreshing so light all right
sauces we have a selection of sauces
here we have tons of sauces we have our
very iconic salt and pepper and sesame
oil you have your samjhang you also have
your own line of sauces and then you can
be actually like me and have your kpop
sauces we have like a triple x gochujang
sauce a honey glaze sauce that's very
similar to what we had on the pork belly
and then your traditional gochujang
wraps are also very important in korean
barbecue
what wraps do we have here today so we
have some perilla leaf
we have some lettuce with some very
thinly sliced daikon and some rice paper
well with all these elements
chris can you show me your perfect
korean bbq bite my pleasure i'm going to
take a nice fresh broiler leaf we have a
little thinly sliced daikon and then i
like to do a little jalapeno
a little bit of garlic and a nice dollop
of the uh samjang sauce and then some of
the meat the perfect bite
that looks so good i'm gonna try it but
let me show you my perfect fight first i
have my meat i'm gonna dip it in my
sesame oil salt pepper sauce and then
i'm gonna take my oh yes
kimchi and then radish paper i put it on
top and then i scoop it like this
cheers
no word that was
a very perfect bite uh but the great
thing about korean bbq is whatever bite
you make will be the perfect bite and
there's so many different flavors so
many different side dishes that you can
mix and match to invent your new perfect
bite there are billions of combinations
of bites on this table that you could
literally create in one city this was an
amazing experience yeah it was everyone
at home now you know how to make perfect
korean bbq at home or if you're trying
it for the first time at a restaurant
you know what to expect but for people
who are interested in renting out this
korean bbq car how can they do that that
is a great question you can go check out
the website it's kbbqcar.com
um our instagram is the same thing k bbq
car and if you guys try korean bbq or
make korean barbecue at home make sure
to snap a picture and tag us on
instagram so we can see that's right
bye
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you